If you’re watching this, you probably have
seen at least one video by Business Casual.
The channel is a great example of what’s
possible in terms of business entertainment
content on YouTube and is definitely an influence
on some of my videos, but the channel went
silent about a year ago and I wanted to find
out why, so I dug into it.
Even if you’ve never heard of the channel
before, I think you’ll want to stick around
and watch this video, it’s a really interesting
story that highlights a darker side of entrepreneurship
we don’t often hear about.
Usually, when YouTube channels die off, they
do it slowly.
The content gets boring and repetitive and
view numbers start declining, but that’s
not the case for Business Casual.
The last video on the channel got nearly 2
million views and, at 40 minutes long, it
was clearly a ton of work to put together.
So why would a successful channel like Business
Casual just throw in the towel all of a sudden?
The answer was not what I was expecting at
all and contains a really important lesson
for entrepreneurs working on any big project,
not just YouTube creators.
Long story short, the folks behind Business
Casual are suing YouTube, which is pretty
weird because it seems like YouTube has been
quite good to the channel in general.
Business Casual has nearly a million subscribers
and none of their content seems to be controversial
or demonetized.
But if you scroll through the Business Casual
twitter feed, you will see that whoever is
running the account now is on a crusade against
YouTube.
In fact, the Twitter account has posted basically
the same tweet every day for the last 100
days straight, so I had to figure out what
was driving this.
As a little bit of backstory, Business Casual
was started by this guy, Jordan Kouzmanoff.
He lives in Bulgaria and started the channel
back in 2016 when he was studying business
at the Rotterdam School of Management.
I went back through some of his old reddit
posts and he seems like a really genuine guy.
He’s just super interested in entrepreneurial
stories and explaining business concepts in
clear and creative ways.
The channel grew significantly over the past
few years and he was even able to bring on
a narrator and animators to help make the
videos.
The channel currently has about 80 million
views, which means it easily could have generated
a million dollars in revenue across YouTube
ads and sponsorship deals.
But looking at Jordan’s LinkedIn profile,
it looks like he ended his relationship with
the channel in September of 2019.
So I started looking into what happened around
that time.
I’m not 100% sure, but it looks like he
either sold part or all of the channel to
a guy named Alex Edson, who runs a company
in Scottsdale, Arizona named eBrands.
This guy Alex has started a few different
businesses and has been involved with a bunch
of YouTube channels over the past few years.
And it’s Alex’s name on the YouTube lawsuit
that Business Casual is filing.
So it looks like Alex is really the one driving
everything now and constantly posting to Twitter.
Interestingly, the Business Casual twitter
account actually posted the full 243-page
lawsuit against YouTube, Google, and Alphabet,
and so I read through it to get an idea of
what’s really going on here.
Basically, the lawsuit comes down to some
pretty standard copyright infringement claims.
Essentially, it looks like another YouTube
channel took clips from Business Casual videos
and used them in new videos without permission
from the Business Casual team.
For obvious reasons, I’m not going to show
any of the copyrighted footage, but if you
want to check it out, I’ll link to the clips
in the description below.
The actual offending clips are fairly short,
one is just 7 seconds long, and it’s just
a slow zoom on a public domain image.
It’s clear that the video was stolen, but
it’s not like they reuploaded a whole video
or anything like that.
YouTube actually did take down the videos
that contained the offending clips, but Alex
Edson doesn’t seem to think that’s enough.
And this is where it gets really interesting.
See, the channels that used the copyrighted
footage from Business Casual were affiliated
with RT, which is a Russian state-controlled
network.
RT used to be called Russia Today, and has
been accused of spreading disinformation and
conspiracy theories.
In fact, in 2017, RT America was ordered to
register as a foreign agent with the United
States Department of Justice.
So when I first saw the tweets from Business
Casual and the lawsuit, I thought that maybe
this was a personal vendetta.
Jordan, the original creator of the channel,
is from Bulgaria after all and Bulgaria’s
relationship with Russia has been deteriorating
over the past decade.
I assumed that Jordan had taken the copyright
infringement as an opportunity to punish Russia
and maybe he had some personal family history
with Russia that motivated him to stop making
new videos just to focus on this lawsuit,
but now I think it’s more complicated.
Jordan isn’t listed on any of the lawsuit
filings and it doesn’t look like he’s
affiliated with the channel in a meaningful
way anymore.
Alex Edson, on the other hand, is on every
email thread with RT and YouTube representatives
and seems to be the sole driving force behind
the lawsuit.
So why does this entrepreneur from Arizona
want to get Russia Today kicked off YouTube
so badly?
Well, there are a few factors here.
First is the obvious political angle.
Russia has been a major American rival for
the past hundred years and tensions between
Russia and America were particularly high
during the Cold War.
More recently, Russian interference in the
2016 United States election became an extremely
hot topic.
Donald Trump was a deeply unpopular President
throughout his time in office, and many of
his detractors hold Russia accountable for
his election.
More recently though, the narrative has flipped
a bit.
With Trump kicked off of nearly every social
media platform, conservatives have been asking
the question, why is the President of the
United States banned from social media, but
Russia’s state-run account aren’t?
So it’s possible that Alex Edson has a strong
stance here, and wants to get Russia kicked
off of YouTube for political reasons, but
I actually think there’s another layer to
this story…
I’m not a legal expert, but the Business
Casual lawsuit looks weak.
We’re talking about a few short clips used
for just a few seconds on channels that publish
dozens of videos per day.
YouTube should definitely take them down,
and Business Casual should receive the advertising
revenue from those videos, since they produced
the original content, but it looks like the
footage was used in the context of a larger
video and the RT channels weren’t directly
reuploading whole videos from Business Casual
in order to steal ad revenue.
If you consider the actual economic damage
done to the Business Casual channel here,
it looks pretty minimal.
The clips were used on Arabic channels, and
Business Casual doesn’t even post content
in Arabic, so there isn’t really a good
argument that people would watch the stolen
videos instead of Business Casual’s original
content, thus depriving them of views and
ad revenue.
But I think Alex is playing a bigger economic
game with this lawsuit.
See, YouTube and really all the big tech companies
are under immense pressure right now from
the U.S.
Government.
As I’ve mentioned in previous videos, both
Elizabeth Warren on the left, and Josh Hawley
on the right, are calling to break up big
tech companies.
The last thing YouTube needs right now is
a lawsuit gaining steam that makes them look
like they are helping spread Russian disinformation.
So this case could just get settled out of
court.
Essentially, YouTube might just pay Alex to
go away.
That could be a great outcome for him.
Even though Business Casual brings in decent
viewer numbers and probably makes thousands
of dollars every month, that content costs
a lot to produce, and getting a big payday
from YouTube could be significantly more profitable.
Regardless of what happens with the lawsuit,
it looks like Business Casual isn’t working
on any new content at the moment, so if you’re
looking to hear interesting stories about
successful companies, you should subscribe
to my channel.
I just put out a great story about how Discord
grew into a multi-billion dollar company and
next week will be releasing the full story
of Epic Games, who created Fortnite.
In every video, I try to not only tell the
story of the company in an engaging way, but
also pull out some key takeaways that any
entrepreneur could apply to their own business.
And there’s a big takeaway here about the
Business Casual story.
Getting copied happens all the time in business,
sometimes it’s a direct copy, and you can
take legal action, but sometimes it’s just
a competitive business and you can’t do
anything about it.
Regardless, you can’t lose sight of what
you’re building.
The Business Casual fanbase just wants to
watch engaging documentaries about business,
and all this focus on suing YouTube doesn’t
help them at all.
When I started my first company, Soylent,
someone in Russia funnily enough actually
put up a copycat website designed to steal
customer’s credit card information.
People thought they were buying from us, but
they were actually just sending money directly
to these Russian hackers.
It was annoying, but we didn’t let it distract
us from our mission of making a great product.
If someone copies you, it might be extremely
frustrating, but you can’t let it consume
you.
You need to stay focused on your business.
There is another option for Business Casual
though.
One that would let them put pressure on Russian
media while still making great content.
They could start making videos about this
whole story!
The most successful channels on YouTube are
personality driven, and I know I would definitely
watch behind the scenes content of Alex Edson’s
fight against Russian media.
That would be extremely interesting content
and I think a lot of the Business Casual fanbase
would follow along.
Regardless of what you think about Russia,
or where you stand on copyright infringement,
I think we can all agree it’s unfortunate
when a channel that produces great content
just stops.
In the meantime, please consider watching
some of the videos on my channel, the YouTube
algorithm thinks you’ll like this one in
particular.